ghislain kuen vie à taiwan il s'est
déplacé spécialement pour enseigner le
kung fu traditionnel à villepreux
c'est difficile parce que ça a l'air
facile quand on le voit il ya pas de sot
il n'y a pas de choses très très
spectaculaire ce qui est difficile c'est
que ça demande beaucoup beaucoup de
force dans les jambes puisque on va
utiliser les jambes les hanches pour
tourner pour frapper ce qui est
difficile aussi c'est apprendre à
respirer quand on frappe et il faut être
un petit peu souple cet expert 3e dan
international transmet les clés du kung
fu aux cinquante participants
il est le représentant européen de m
lumengo oui je suis un amoureux des arts
martiaux plus particulièrement du kung
fu je commence à me diversifier
diversifier un peu mais de base vient du
kung fu et donc du beau show que j'ai
pratiqué à pendant pas mal de temps
en parallèle de la boxe est hélas
aujourd'hui personnellement c'est un
grand jour pour moi parce que je
retrouve énormément de gens justement de
ce milieu c'est à la fois une journée de
retrouvailles
une journée de partage et c'est une
vraie d'entraînement donc je suis venu à
la fois pour les gens et pour
l'entraînement je suis extrêmement
contente de pouvoir rpt pratiques et des
bases de d'arts martiaux traditionnels
chinois
sachant que c'est quelque chose qui est
de plus en plus difficiles à trouver
y compris en région parisienne y compris
en france et que même même en chine ça
commence à disparaître un peu cette
journée était organisée par pro fight
pour aider les réfugiés tibétains de
villepreux pas requis jeudi
le tarif de ce stage était libre on
connaît bien la cause des tibétains
et on était particulièrement sensible à
leur venue et
on a voulu faire un moment de partage
avec eux malgré qu'ils sont partis jeudi
dernier à mantes-la-ville les recettes
perçues lors de ce stage iront
intégralement à l'association acr au
profit des réfugiés tibétains